- Пане Брок, "формула Штайнмаєра", на яку Україна погодилася, -
на Вашу думку, це ключ до вирішення конфлікту на Донбасі
чи капітуляція України?
- Це не капітуляція, а питання послідовності:
що коли відбувається.
Тут Україні треба бути уважною, щоб певні умови були виконані.
Наприклад, щоб могли голосувати українці, які втекли з Донбасу.
Ясно, що там мають бути вільні ЗМІ,
щоб ОБСЄ могла належним чином контролювати вибори,
щоб виборчі комісії укомплектовані як слід.
Або ж питання того, що Україна має отримати
контроль над українсько-російським кордоном.
- І коли Україна має отримати цей контроль?
Та що може ЄС зробити, аби допомогти цьому?
Перед тим, як відбудуться ці вільні вибори.
Україна повинна мати контроль над кордоном.
Я вбачаю в контролі над кордоном умову для проведення виборів.
- То що може зробити ЄС, аби посприяти цьому?
- Ми маємо про це заявити, коли відбудеться
зустріч у "нормандському форматі".
Підтримка з боку ЄС має бути чіткою.
Ми як Євросоюз не повинні тиснути на Україну,
аби та пішла на хибну послідовність кроків, що призведе до капітуляції.
Натомість повинна бути дотримана правильна послідовність
в інтересах незалежної та вільної України.
- Олександр Данилюк подав у відставку з посади секретаря РНБО України
лише за кілька місяців перебування на посаді.
Що це означає? Чи переміг олігарх
Ігор Коломойський у боротьбі за вплив на Зеленського?
- Я не знаю, чи це Коломойський.
Але це точно пов'язано з бюрократичною спритністю пана Богдана,
якщо я правильно зрозумів пана Данилюка, з яким я про це говорив.
Мене тривожить, що в Офісі президента, очевидно,
є різні групи, які борються за вплив.
Я сподіваюся, що при цьому на першому місці
стоятиме незалежна, демократична правова держава Україна.
Це важливо для просування її інтеграції із Заходом.
- Данилюк вважався важливим співрозмовником
для західних партнерів. Після його відставки
чи втратила Україна в очах Заходу?
- Нас тривожить боротьба за владу в Офісі президента.
Тому важливо, щоб зберігалася співпраця з Данилюком та іншими.
Треба слідкувати, аби з відповідальних посад
не витискали все більше та більше прозахідних людей,
які відстоюють демократію та верховенство права в Україні,
наприклад, незалежність Верховного суду.
- У телефонній розмові з Трампом Зеленський
дуже критично висловився, що ЄС і Німеччина
недостатньо роблять для України.
Чи втратив таким чином Зеленський підтримку західних лідерів?
- Ми ж знаємо телефонні прийоми пана Трампа.
А Зеленський тільки нещодавно обійняв посаду,
тож слова Зеленського в розмові з Трампом
ми не дозволимо використати як підставу, аби відносини погіршилися.
Але треба чітко розуміти, що ЄС плюс фінансові інституції,
плюс держави-члени за останні п'ять років надали
грантів, кредитів і гарантій на приблизно 18 мільярдів євро.
Ми провели візову лібералізацію та уклали
угоду про вільну торгівлю, яка спричинила
значне зростання експорту з України до ЄС.
Американці надають щороку один і той самий мільярд
як гарантії під дешеві кредити, щоб Україна могла
купувати американську зброю.
Ми робимо у 15-20 разів більше для України,
ніж США. І це також мають розуміти в Україні.
- Але не в питанні оборони.
США допомагають Україні передусім в обороні.
ЄС у цьому робить менше.
- Для того, аби там розвивалася держава,
ніхто і близько стільки не робить, скільки Євросоюз і його держави-члени.
Україна була б банкрутом, не було б
торговельної угоди з усіма її перевагами,
не було би візової лібералізації.
Усе це було зроблено для розвитку України не з боку США.
До речі, торговельний баланс між США і Росією зріс,
тож за санкції платить Європа, а не США.
А вони отримують зиск від санкцій.
Отака реальність.
Причина - в торговельних зв'язках, які склалися,
в географічному положенні.
Але після цього казати, що Євросоюз нічого не робить...
Так, ми не продаємо зброю, щонайменше не всі з нас.
Деякі держави це роблять.
Американці ж не дарують зброю, вони її продають.
Якщо поглянути на телефонну розмову, то Трамп
постійно запрошує Зеленського купувати зброю та газ.
Там постійно слово "продавати", а не давати.
Це треба брати до уваги. Ми могли би помінятися:
ми не робимо нічого з 18 мільярдів євро,
а даємо гарантії на один мільярд, як американці,
а ви купуйте зброю у нас. Чи допоможе це Україні?
- Але чи має ЄС робити більше?
- Ми робимо у 20 разів більше, ніж американці.
- Трамп на днях заявив, що до Зеленського в Україні
була "велетенська корупція". Чи згодні Ви з цим?
- В Україні була жахлива корупція
і за часів Януковича, і ще раніше.
За часів Порошенка її не позбулися цілковито,
хоча вона і зменшилася.
І над цим треба далі працювати.
Тому добре, що Зеленський працює над тим,
аби зменшити корупцію. Це розвиток, але
корупція в Україні й досі не подолана.
- Але Ви бачите зрушення за останні місяці?
- Я бачу прогрес у боротьбі з корупцією
протягом п'яти років. Варто лише подивитися
на е-декларації... Так, усе це недостатньо швидко.
Я сподіваюся, буде швидше.
Але ситуація не є чорно-білою.
Пік корупції був за Януковича.
Моя критика на адресу Порошенка в тому, що
він із різних причин не був достатньо швидким
і достатньо жорстким.
Але порівняння, які робить Трамп, завжди дуже грубі.
- Навесні - до та одразу після президентських виборів
в Україні - настрій тут, у Брюсселі, був:
зачекаємо і подивимося, ким є Зеленський
і що він робитиме. Зараз
чи сформували ви вже думку про нього?
- Ми все ще позитивно сприймаємо.
Його політика загалом є позитивною.
У прийнятті законів, зокрема в економічній сфері,
на які вже давно чекали, є справжній поступ.
Але в частині прийнятих законів, можливо,
є помилки, оскільки їх дуже швидко ухвалювали.
Зокрема в судовій реформі, децентралізації
та законі про Київ. Усе це нас тривожить.
Тут потрібен час, потрібні певні процеси,
щоб несподівано не вийшло так, що корупція
стане на заваді розвитку в Україні демократії,
верховенства права, а також інтеграції з Заходом.
Я не хочу, щоб виникали такі ситуації
через неуважність або через те, що цього хочуть деякі люди.
- Коли ми з Вами говорили одразу після першого туру виборів,
Ви дали українцям пораду добре зважити,
чи варто обирати президентом новачка в політиці.
І все ж його обрали.
Ваше занепокоєння справдилося чи ні?
- Очевидно, що Порошенко хибно оцінював ситуацію.
Ми постійно спонукали його робити швидше певні реформи,
але він не дослухався до цих закликів і,
як наслідок, за його президентства процес реформ,
попри всі успіхи, та прогрес не був достатньо швидким.
А це було очікуванням людей на Майдані:
молодих людей, які хочуть бачити реформи в Україні.
І тепер нинішнє керівництво має слідкувати,
щоб їхнім мріям і очікуванням
знову не стали на заваді бюрократичні перепони.
- Знову і знову з'являються новини про справи
або допити в НАБУ, в ДБР
високопосадовців часів Порошенка.
Чи бачите ви політичне переслідування опозиції в Україні?
- Зараз я цього поки не бачу, але тиск є значним.
Звісно, з більшістю в 60% від складу парламенту
це небезпечно,
але за всієї потреби швидко ухвалювати
рішення та закони не повинно бути так, що
парламентарі - чи то з більшості, чи з опозиції, -
не мають часу розібратися в законах, які приймають.
Якщо парламент, як зараз,
стає друкарським верстатом, коли вранці
законопроєкт вносять на комітет, після обіду
голосує парламент, а ввечері його вже підписали,
то це вже не є відкритим і прозорим процесом
законотворення за участі народу.
- Ви кілька тижнів обіймаєте цю позицію -
радника голови Єврокомісії.
Які поради Ви даєте Юнкеру щодо України?
- Я не казатиму, які я поради даю пану Юнкеру.
Це я кажу лише пану Юнкеру. Але в цьому інтерв'ю
я висловив деякі побоювання.
Ми хочемо наголосити, що загалом
думка про цю владу є позитивною.
Ми сподіваємося, що через певний розвиток подій,
який перебуває поза нашим контролем,
справи не підуть у хибному напрямі,
через що всі згодом шкодуватимуть.
Коли ми надали ці 18 мільярдів, то ми очікуємо,
що в підсумку постане держава, яка
є демократичною, з верховенством права, без корупції.
Адже саме така і економічно сильна Україна
є найкращою відповіддю на російську агресію.
- Чи могли б Ви трохи розповісти,
як Вам працюється спеціальним радником?
- У мене настільки довге політичне життя, що
робота тут точно не найскладніша.
Ви, ймовірно, знаєте, що я регулярно
відвідую Україну протягом 20 років.
І там я відчуваю багато радості, а також
дружу з багатьма людьми. Але це ще й
питання відповідальності.
Незалежна вільна Україна - це найкраща безпека Європи.
І особливо ми, німці, маємо докладати зусиль.
Коли я бачу, як Пакт Молотова-Ріббентропа
віддав Західну Україну Радянському Союзу,
то це також частина нашої німецької
історичної відповідальності, яку ми маємо нести.
- Дуже Вам вдячний за Ваш час і відповіді!